[Music]
fang
heart spine talon
and tail long ago the five lands lived
together in harmony
then everything changed when the drew
nation attacked
only the dragons could stop them but
when the world needed the most
they vanished 500 years passed and raya
discovered the last dragon
a water dragon named sisu and although
her magic skills are great
she has a lot to learn before she's
ready to save anyone
but raya believes sisu can save the
world
riotar the last air dragon the avatar
the
i mean raya and the last dragon
journey to kamandra a melting pot of
southeast asian cultures
and east asian voice actors to meet raya
an orphan warrior princess and total
dragon nerd
i might be a little bit of a dragon nerd
you're not the only dragon nerd here
which in a world created by dragons
means she's super religious
raya will find a savior who can walk on
water when she awakens sisu
an orphaned cross between a thai naga
and a stretched out my little pony
who can disguise herself as a cross
between aquafina and an e-girl on
laundry day
together sisu will teach raya the
importance of learning to trust
others while the movie will teach you to
never trust anyone
in a different world maybe we could have
been friends you're going to tell me
where i can find those
other dragon gem pieces who's baby
what
you have to give a little trust first
it was foolish to trust someone from
fact don't come any closer
you're saying give people a chance but
you're showing that chaos is a letter
travel across this richly detailed land
so quickly
you wish they had an avatar length tv
series to explore it further
as you spend barely enough time with the
orphan boone a tragic victim of
millennial hustle culture
i'm captain boone the owner chef and
chief financial officer of the shrimp
oil
noy a tiny orphan martial artist who
feels like an exchange student from the
boss baby franchise
and tong a likely orphan who's lost his
only child
hey wait a second raya sisu boon noi
tong
did disney just pull off the rare
quintuple orphan gang
bravo that is some really efficient
parent killing right there
heroes beware dark clouds are gathering
on the horizon
not metaphorically the bad guy is
literally dark clouds
because when you unleash the imagination
of disney animators
these days they'll come back with what
if cloud but bad
and with a villain this lane you better
hope the real enemy was inside us all
along or whatever
as the main antagonist turns out to be
raya's on again off again maybe
friendship may be something more with
namari
she may have doomed them all when they
were kids it's fangs now
she may have doomed them all again when
they grew up
she may be dooming everyone outside of
her own tribe we need to expand
if we had all the gem pieces we could do
that safely
but when you really think about it
aren't the heroes just as much to blame
for triggering the end of the world
but you're as much to blame for sisu's
death as i am
actually no no she is not i'm sorry but
no we've been watching the movie
you shot her no so try to stomach a
story that feels like it was let's say
reincarnated from another franchise with
enough 2010's banter to repeatedly take
you out of it
do you mean captain poppin lock over
there here i was worried you were gonna
end up becoming a cat lady
something tells me you're not besties
bling is my thing but even on a crappy
laptop screen
you'll be rewarded with better visuals
than the itunes visualizer on edibles
i mean just look at that water since
seeing how real that looks it's like a
water deep fake
if i were real water i'd be worried
starring
an exclusive dating app fail core
does alan tudyk even remember how to
sound like people anymore
[Music]
zuko i know everything there is to know
about the shrimping business
let me see that tong avoid the noi
daniel dead kim and when you really want
to say the b
word but you're in a disney movie she's
the backstabbing venturi but
bye ben turries pay up venturi let's
finish this venturi
bye bye binturi no good benturi's
benturi now that's not a very nice way
to describe an old friend
the life aquatic with team sisu
whoa i got the glow look calling
yourself the last dragon if you must but
don't compare yourself to the real ass
dragon
you're not gonna win who's the one
[Music]
maybe the real mephisto was the friends
we made along the way
that makes you the scarlett johansson do
you understand the words that are coming
out of my mouth
it's never lupus what is beef
if not cow persevering